hey guys it's Johanna here so this is a
frequently asked question by some of you
on how can you achieve a sharper and
slimmer looking face basically to lose
fat on the face well if you have seen my
ask Joyner videos you will know that it
is not possible to spot reduce fat when
you lose weight you lose overall this
include the fat from your face and
sometimes puffiness on the face can be
caused by bloatedness so here are my
five tips to help you achieve a sharper
and slimmer looking face just by making
small changes to your diet and lifestyle
the first tip is to reduce your salt and
sugar intake at times great gain in the
face is the result of water retention
rather than body fat consuming too much
or refined sugar and salt can cause
water retention hence making your face
look fatter the easiest way to prove
this is if you were to have french fries
fast food high sugar chocolate bars late
night right before bedtime chances are
when you wake up the next morning you
will notice that your face is puffy than
usual and you will feel bloated
so just by reducing salt and refined
sugar from your diet not only will you
lose fat from the face you will lose fat
overall in to consume lots of vegetables
and eat real food as part of a healthy
and balanced diet the second tip is to
drink plenty of water if you're not
drinking enough water your body is more
likely to retain water reason being is
that your body things there isn't enough
water so it is desperate to store excess
water to keep your body from dehydration
and unfortunately most of this routine
water stays in the cheeks and eyes hence
making them look puffier and fatter
personally this happens to me a lot when
I'm traveling and struggle to keep
myself hydrated as often as I should so
drink plenty of water to flush out all
the body toxins when your body is in
desperate to retain excess water that's
when you will achieve a slimmer and
sharper looking face
drink at least 2.5 to 3 liters of water
in a day the third tip is to watch your
weight if you have a chubby face due to
being overweight or obese then the
easiest way to lose fat from the face is
to lose fat overall so change your
lifestyle start a workout plan and go on
a healthy and balanced diet usually
excess body fat will disappear first
from the face if you are unsure where to
start they click on this link here as I
will guide you through my seven steps to
permanent weight loss the fourth tip is
to avoid alcohol alcohol is another
common culprit when it comes to facial
and body weight gain drinking too much
of alcohol leads to dehydration which
then causes water retention and
puffiness in the face alcohol contains
mostly empty calories and has no
nutritional values one gram of alcohol
has seven calories and that is only
second to fat so for instance drinking
two pints of 5 percent strength beer at
170 calories per pine has more calories
than a Meg DS cheese burger most of the
time we are more aware of the food we
eat however we can be delusional on how
much we drink so if you have been
watching a weight and doing regular
exercises but you are not losing the
weight perhaps it can be due to your
alcohol consumption avoid or limit your
alcohol intake for a slimmer looking
face and body of course that does not
mean you can't have a good night out
occasionally one tip to reduce all your
alcohol intake is to alternate between
the drinks and water water will help to
keep your body hydrated and also to
reduce on your alcohol and the final tip
is to perform facial exercises try some
simple jaw exercises profoundly
pronounce the letters X o a lot of times
so exaggerated and open your mouth as
wide as you can and
close is so x o X 0x o and repeat this
for 30 times in three different sessions
this will work on the facial muscles
alternatively
two chewing gums this will also work on
the facial muscles and avoid you from
munching away or if you want to pamper
yourself then go for a facial massage
massage helps to increase the
circulation of the tissues in your face
giving you a slimmer face and more
evenly toned if all these facial
exercises are not possible then the
easiest and best way is to smile and
laugh on a daily basis laughing engages
more than the facial muscles it works on
your abs and your heart too so by the
reason to smell and laugh every day for
a younger and human looking face and a
joyful heart the more positive energy
you give out the more you will receive
in return so the key to get a swimmer
and shop a licking face is to lose fat
and excess water in the body and of
course learning certain makeup
techniques can help too I hope these
tips have helped you out and please do
share other tips which have worked for
you the best for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my You Tube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
you